everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we're in round nine
of our coverage the 2017 a US Chess
Championships been a good one so far
today's competitors whites going to be
played by Jeffrey strong he's a 16 year
old Grandmaster actually won the 2016 US
closed Junior Championships he's the
highest rated player in the US under the
age of 18 and he in the world he's the
second highest rated player under the
age of 18 his rating is 2674 words
extremely high only about 150 points
lower than Wesley so which his opponent
today and Wesley the second highest
rated player in the world other is
playing probably better than anyone even
Magnus Carlsen he beat him in the last
tournament they play Wesley so is
currently tied for the lead with Fatih
Cobian and so he's going to be looking
to have a really strong performance with
the black pieces today we'll go and get
into it Geoffrey starts with pawn to d4
Knight f6 pawn c4 and then pond e6
getting into the Catalan opening upon g3
getting ready and headed to Bishop here
to a g2 on the kingside pawn down to d5
so this is the Queen's Gambit decline a
bishop to g2 and then at Bishop e7 a
black kinda has two options
you know Bishop to e7 Castle on the
Kings side or the other option would be
to go ahead and take this material right
here it's going to be difficult to hold
on to this awesome to just see Queen to
a4 right away
Bishop to d7 Queen takes here on c4 so
more more players are opting not to take
this material here on c4 and just play
it safe play Bishop here to e7 Knight to
f3 castle on the King side and Castle
over here what being should actually see
if you know white takes here so he
doesn't have to worry about this pond
taking on c4 and then trying to get that
material back later in the game the pawn
recaptures now he can cast on the King
side if he wants who still has to
central pawn and it's pretty good for
white but decides to go ahead and after
castle on the King side Castle his own
way and then after the pawn takes Queen
up here to see - he has a few options he
could play Queen to a4 he could play
Knight to e5 all of these attacking this
pawn all these moves so far though
the players are taking less than 10
seconds per mo
so you can tell they're very familiar
with the lines they're comfortable and
so Queen to see do definitely seems like
it was in Jeffrey's preparation what's
the so it continues with pawn to a6
preparing himself to push forward upon
to be five wide see that stops that
right away with pawn to a4 Bishop d7
just developing pieces slowly rook to d1
you know I think it makes sense also if
you just want to get that material back
Queen takes on c4 but first plays rook
here to d1 Bishop d6 also has to be
aware of the knight coming to e5 opening
up the door for his LightSquared bishop
on g2 to attack this long diagonal this
pawn here on b7 would then be a weakness
so first plays at Bishop to c6 stopping
that Knight up to c3 Bishop takes Bishop
recaptures Knight to c6 and Jeffrey
decides to go ahead and take give his
double Bishop pair up in exchange for
these three pawns on the C file so
blacks not going to be able to hold on
to all these ponds we've already talked
about you know white can get this
material here on c4 when he wants to but
that's kind of what he's going for in
this game trying to have a better pawn
structure going in towards the endgame
Bishop to g5 completing his development
getting a dark square bishop involved
into the game rook to b8 controlling the
semi open file to just open up and then
pawn to e3 up into this point Jeffrey's
pretty much been taking less than 10
seconds every single move III was the
first time where he took about 20
minutes so really trying to figure out
how he wanted to continue on board
decided to go ahead and solidify his
pawn chain in the center of the board
Wesley decides now that since he has
triple pawns on the C file and it's
going to be difficult for him to hold on
to all of this he needs to use them to
the best of his ability and blowing up
the center control that White has right
now seems like a pretty good plan so
pawn to c5 after the exchange the rook
on d1 is now attacking the Queen Queens
forced to move comes here to eh and then
work up to a d4 logging-in a selfie
wants you to have a really strong an
attack on the King side of the board he
could also double barrel he wants to
prepare for the rook to come over here
to d1 really control this central file
with his rooks and then I'd appear to be
said
doesn't have the option if you look and
say let's go ahead and take that pawn
but doesn't get a little tricky with her
over here to h4 Bishop can exchange but
then this Queen also is attacking the
square here on h7
so pawn to HDX forcing the bishop to
move Bishop takes could see an exchange
on board Knight to e4 just good little
tricky attacking both the bishop and the
pawn here on f6 we see Queen these have
really the only option for black it does
defend both of these critical squares
then clean up here to c3 preparing now
for my takes on f6 just blowing up the
King side of the board pawn to e5 and
then Queen up here taking on a c4 black
is just really in a tough spot right now
and has to worry about so many attacks
on the King side of the board so he
decides go ahead and play Knight to d7
and then we see an exchange of bishops
come off the board on e7 and then pot up
here to c6 so didn't do a good job of
pushing putting on a pressure on Wesley
so even though it doesn't have a lot of
protection on this pawn
decides he wants to push that as much as
possible so the knight comes back here
to e5 attacking the pawn and then we see
a clean up here to e4 protecting this
pawn here on c6 and both sides you'll
start to see consolidate in the center
the board and see if either person can
make a mistake Queen down here to c5
Knight up here to d5 has the option to
just take some recapturing I guess you
looked at and said I'm not sure that's
the best variation for me just had to go
and play Knight down here to d3 naught
and then I'd up here to c7 you know it
starts a little crazy from here you know
as far as how black can continue he
could either take with this rook down
here on b2 probably makes the most
logical sense you always want to get
your rooks down to the second rank you
can just put a lot of pressure on your
opponent but from here it's it's pretty
straightforward as far as what white is
going to do he's either a just going to
maybe take here on c4 attack this clean
or he's going to play rook over here to
f1 those are really as only options what
I really like Wesley so because he
played Knight to f2 in this this gives
white more options some of which are
really really
bad because the best place for white
right now is to go with a little
different exchange not to take this
night here on f2 but to go ahead and say
okay I take here on a6 and then you're
going to take my queen I'm going to take
your queen you're going to take my
Knights I'm going to swing over here a
take the pawn here on c4 you're going to
have a minor piece but I'm going to have
these three passed pawns and I'm going
to try to push those up the board I
think of that I think Geoffrey has a
pretty good game here this nights going
to have a tough time stopping all of
these past pawns
I can't be super aggressive he has to
play pretty defensive in this spot but
if we come back to it after the knight
comes down to f/2 Geoffrey decided to go
ahead and take it with his king and
that's dangerous because the rook coming
down here to be to check and then after
King to f1 then Queen over here to h5
just putting a lot of pressure getting
ready to come down to e2 that would be a
quick checkmate on board
so now you know Jeffrey's forced to just
play completely defensive where we had a
very very aggressive line if you had
just taken the Knights here the pawn on
a6
so why continues with Queen to g4 trying
to exchange but that's not what this
game is about Queen taking down on h2
threatening mate just Queen to f2 would
be made really only way to stop that is
clean down here to f3 and then why okay
there's a passed pawns to starting to
push in this board pawn here to c3 Rick
over here to see one has to stop it as
much as possible upon to e5 attacking
the rook rook over here to h4 and this
is probably another one of those
mistakes where rook to c4 makes a lot of
sense this past pawn is very dangerous
and you want both of your rooks to
attack that what you don't want is to
get your work completely on the opposite
side of the board because soon as the
work comes over here this Queen can move
the rook can come over here to d8
control this file now and there's just
too much pressure on the Queen side of
board from these two rooks and this pawn
good after rook to h4 Queen over here to
d2 and now this rook is kind of
completely out of the equation which is
not what white is looking for right now
rook to d1 and then
here to ad8 and so this is this is kind
of tough he can't just take it here on
d2 because then rook down to d2 getting
ready to push forward with pawn to c2 at
some point he's threatening just mate
right away
rook down to be one would essentially
threaten the Queen to just come off the
board and then it'd be mate so King to
g1 is kind of a forced move rook down to
b1 and then the Queen's going to fall
and then rook to d1 king can come here
to eat ooh that's fine but then pawned
c2 it's going to promote to a queen and
why it's definitely going to fall here
so we see that y can't take that Queen
right here just has to go and play
Knight to d5 he does have protection
from this Queen but unfortunately for
him it doesn't protect as much as he
would like it's actually going to be a
free rook or a free night here on d5
because if he were to take let's say
queen takes here on d5 well then it's
just checkmate okay well that's kind of
a bummer
what if instead we take the Queen here
on d2 I will now the rook takes and
we're kind of in that same situation as
before
rook threatening to come to b1 and
there's no ways to really stop the Queen
from falling and then to even push this
pawn down here to see one for a queen so
after the rook takes the knight on d5
then work over here to d4 and this is
kind of I like this effort because it
says hey if you take correctly you know
you're probably going to win but if you
take incorrectly let's say that this
pawn here on e5 takes this rook
okay well now it's very dangerous
because pond is c7 is threatening a mate
because pawn c8 check with the Queen the
roof's forced to come over here and then
we have a back ranked main so black now
has to worry about that threat he could
play pawn to g6 opening up a door for is
king and escape path then pawn up the CA
check and then King to g7 but now the
Queen's going to fall and then you know
pawn takes on d2 getting ready to push
but then Queen down here to be one
stopping at two Queens first two rooks
why it's going to win this every single
day if we come back and say it lets pawn
doesn't come here to g6 maybe Queen over
here too
- really the only other option that he
has even though none of these options
are good in this situation the queen
takes black rook comes over here then
the King takes rook here to c5
threatening this pawn which is fine
open-ended recovered here to a d4 and
the rook can't take on c7 because it
just would be checkmate on the back rank
and so this is this is kind of tough
King here to f8 has to kind of stop the
push rook up here to d8 Keeney seven and
then let's just go ahead and get that
Queen you're going to have to give me
your rook and at the endgame White's
going to have a pretty easy game now
fortunately for for Wesley so he decided
correctly to go ahead and just take with
his rook and then after the pawn takes
then the Queen takes here on d1 and in
this position Geoffrey decided to go
ahead and resign there's no way for him
to really get out of this if the King or
the Queen were to come down here to d1
then just pawn to c2 it just kind of
gets out of hand from here he's going to
push forward there's no way to really
stop this you could play Brooke down to
be one depending on where he goes so all
in all congratulations to Wesley so with
the black pieces tied for first place
comes in gets a victory he needed now
the person he's tied with Friday Kobe
and also won today so we do have kind of
a tight race at the top of the US
Championships but all in all exciting
matches especially seeing such a young
player play really well you know I
thought there was one move where he
could have tried something a little bit
different and I think he may have even
had a better in-game with all those past
pawns on the Queen side of board but one
small mistake and Wesley so took
advantage so congratulations to him
thank you guys for watching round 9
we'll come back tomorrow for round 10